[Music]
going away from i'm bad to i'm hurting
but i can fix it is like the biggest
shift ever the reason so many people
tear other people's buildings down is
because they're unhappy
they're unhappy because they don't like
themselves and that's exactly how i want
to live my life
hey guys welcome to the bow show this is
change your mind to change your life
we take some of the world's greatest
minds to steal their knowledge and pass
it on to you to become the best version
of yourself
today i'm joined by the sensational
garyvee
gary vaynerchuk how are you man i'm well
thank you for having me
uh we are so excited to have you evan is
one of your biggest fans he loves your
work we all love your work you're one of
the most popular people on this channel
and i'm really excited for this one
because to me it's the missing
ingredient that most people seem to miss
but if you look at all your content it's
one overall message
so gary i want to talk about deploying
empathy and kindness into business
today great i mean um it is one of my
favorite subject matters and
um and i agree with you i think it's
you know it's so funny so many people
associate me with hustle
and then that word has obviously you
know changed its meaning from hard work
and work ethic
to scam me in a lot of ways and has
a negative connotation in some places um
and i've always wondered why that word
sticks but when i talk heavily about
kindness or empathy
you know maybe maybe it doesn't seem
natural for that to be a big business
trait
but it has absolutely been the
foundation of my success
you think it's a reason because most
people separate their personal lives
from business so they think in their
personal lives they can be an angel i
can be kind compassionate
but they got to be cutthroat in the
business world and it's a
differentiation
do you think that's why i do i do i
think people think nice people get
walked over
nice guys finish last um you know i
think
um you know you got to take what you can
get
i don't i think that i think that's
right i think that's exactly
the insight to why this has been an
issue and it's why i actually
took the subconscious and made it
conscious over the last several years of
my content
because i want people to know that's
just not true a lot of people say to me
gary
you always talk about giving but i i'm
giving and then i get taken advantage of
like you're not getting taken advantage
of
you actually a lot of times weren't
giving in the first place
i think a lot of times people are
manipulating when they make pretend
they're giving i mean the amount of
people like gary
i you know i know you're having a long
flight why don't i pick you up at the
airport and drive you to your hotel what
they're really saying is
hey i'm going to trade you a drive for a
45-minute consultation
and and the last thing i want to do
after a seven-hour flight
is is you know do that i want to catch
up with my family and just kind of relax
for two minutes because i'm on the go go
go
that that wasn't somebody doing
something kind that was somebody trying
to package something selfish
in and i see that little example play
out a lot in business
and and so i i just have not seen the
place where doing the right thing
being kind being a good person um being
compassionate and pathetic sympathetic
was the wrong thing in that scenario now
i do think all those traits are
long-term traits
and and i think that sometimes they are
vulnerable in the short term
um but short-term fast
cash is about the least interesting
thing to me about business
well like one of your biggest things as
well i've learned it's played the long
game and you're you're 100 right man
it's
kindness empathy these are the long game
because they're personal traits they're
your legacy like i know you're very big
on building legacy people are
dude i speak to so many people who know
you personally like dude that guy is a
legend he's such a kind guy
he's exactly what you think he is and
that's carrying over oceans man
so with kindness do you think some
people are
doing it and they're they're trying to
basically get something out of you so
it's a trade so they're using kindness
as a currency and and they're only doing
it for the
elite right they're only doing kindness
to people above them
and they're doing negative things to
people below them
it's the easy bro i see this every day
i see it everywhere people are so
confused
uh they're like gary i'm kind i'm like
no you were you were trying to be kind
to mark
cuban but the way that you spoke to the
person that just took the bag out of
your taxi
a real indicator or or back to your
point i thank you very much for that
there's a lot of people who actually
don't love
me because i may seem too aggressive on
my content
but everybody who's actually spent time
with me has a very different point of
view
in the positive right and um and i know
a lot of people unfortunately the
reverse
you know they seem kind on youtube and
instagram
but their admins hate them so for me
what changed my life is
in business is is adding value without
the
the expectation of receiving something
back so would you say that that's
what you would define yes well i mean
couple yes i i think yes i would i would
say that's a great definition i'm sure
there's some others that i could come up
with
um but i do think it comes from i do
like what you just said
but i but i remind people in the
business context of this
there is an incredible reality there's a
reason
the word karma exists in the english
language
you know like of course doing the right
thing is going to bring good
how can't it if you help somebody
and they know it and you know it they
consciously or subconsciously are going
to bring you value
and i don't i don't know why people
don't look at it in the next game i've
had so many people that i've brought
unlimited kindness to
that have done zero for me and have
absolutely sometimes
other turns brought me negative value
but i don't then say oh
see this doesn't work that's only 39
people
versus the 3 000 that did in that same
pocket of 3039 people
would you say there would be a fear of
some people wanting to
because kindness can be a vulnerability
it's it's opening your heart and it's
going you know what i want to do the
right thing
but i'm afraid someone's going to step
on me like when you did one of your
or it's going to be or it's going to be
a waste of time which
then meant that which then meant you
weren't being kind
you had expectations well that's
one of the things i learned from you
many years ago and i'll touch on it then
is
when as soon as you change your life to
zero expectations of anyone else
you win it's done man it's game over
it's game over
happy dude it's it's game over
and actually that comes out of humility
you you know
i literally don't think i'm in the band
while still believing i'm the best
and that dichotomy is enormous
because it gives you confidence and
ambition
but it's layered with extreme humility
like if i disappear tomorrow
like kobe bryant's one of the most
iconics ever
on and off the field you know he passed
away
in tragic form and
he'll always be remembered but like
everybody's
moving on with their life including his
family that's what you have to do
and so once you realize that once you
realize that you could be
prince you could be david bowie you can
be kobe bryant
and the world will give you 24 to 48
hours if you're that iconic and that
everybody has to move on to your life
that allows you to really navigate in a
different way
which means look i don't in the scheme
of things
we only mean so much at the same token
live your life
in a way that you want to mean the most
to everyone
would you say uh people's entitlement of
what they believe they should have gets
in the way of them
100 i think entitlement is devastating
especially now with that everyone's got
access they believe the access they have
to the internet
entitles everyone to watch their opinion
and when you look at someone like
yourself you've earned it man you
you do the work like to put out the
amount of content you do extraordinary
but
that's not entitled that's earned trust
by the way but i still don't think that
it should happen
i've worked hard i've earned i still
don't think i
deserve it i think it's a byproduct of
the value i'm giving out it's not
you know i love the fruits of labor but
when you work with the market you know
if i was building a fort
out of wood i would understand the
fruits of my work
but when you're trying to win with the
market with
the humans they get to decide not how
many hours there's plenty of people put
forty thousand hours into
their content that nobody's listening to
at all they brought no they didn't bring
enough value it wasn't interesting
or informative or entertaining or
valuable enough and that's
too bad they in theory earned it
but the market said no and so you know i
just don't have any feelings other than
the market is always right and i must
continue to challenge myself to try to
bring value so that the market
values that and if it doesn't it will
tell me and if it does it will tell me
and and there's you know it doesn't
matter what i've done the last 22 years
of my life
it professionally it matters what i do
this hour
and it's also having humility like i'm
in a point in my career i'm very busy
right now like
like even this is a meta example of this
like this is not on paper the best use
of my 25 minutes
but when people ask with passion i like
doing stuff sometimes it's just nice
and and the appreciation there for this
and i'll just say right and i'm logical
about it i know
i wanted to do this because i think bo
you're going to be able to get more
guests because of it
well you know what quick story about how
kindness and empathy works and what your
actions directly do
no about three or four years ago no one
gave me a chance in the world
of doing stuff like this i reached out
to you we did a four minute interview on
your way to your first ever vayner draft
biggest day one of the biggest days of
your life you gave me four minutes
the video still this day hasn't even hit
a thousand views but
one person saw it offered me a job
changed my life
now i work in hollywood i work with
netflix amazon i
do it i live a dream life and that's
because you
use compassion and empathy to go you
know what someone's actually trying to
do something with their heart
and i see that in you so for me thank
you very much because you've
allowed me to to help so many other
hundreds of thousands of people
but that's just an example of how just
saying look i'm gonna use my heart my
passion to do something right so
thank you man i appreciate what you did
for me those many years ago
i really appreciate that and it's and
it's
all i know i don't understand how anyone
doesn't see it
um actually i'm gonna phrase that i
deeply understand why people don't see
it they didn't have the luxury
of dna circumstance and parenting
to give them that perspective i believe
at some level
i'm so grateful for those serendipities
that i'm
guilted at some level slash
motivated to give as much as humanly
possible
in all shapes and forms whether that's a
silent donation
like like right now everyone's
so pressured with everything going in
the world everyone
overly tries to communicate what they do
that's good
i've lived my whole life being quiet
about everything that i've done that's
good
you know um i
i think doing good doesn't need to be
i'm not making videos about the four
minute thing that you just talked about
that's gonna happen
that's your reputation that's gonna
happen in the whispers behind your back
whispers come in two forms the people
that really know you or have interacted
with you and the people that haven't
my ratio of positive sentiment on the
people that have interacted with me
whether it's four
minutes or four years is such
in a greater place than the whispers
behind my back of people that have never
met me once
and that's exactly how i want to live my
life see what's understanding is it's
backtracking a bit but
you've blended there's no such thing it
seems to you i may be wrong but there's
no such thing as your personal life
and your business you live life yes you
have private aspects and that's
respectable you show what you want the
people to see but you live life
and one of your great posts that you
just posted was you're not lazy you're
just not doing what you like and you
love what you do so you that's why
people go he's a machine
no dude if you if you love playing video
games and you do it 23 hours a day
people are gonna think you're productive
a hundred percent a hundred percent and
then
look i you know lebron james is a
machine beyonce is a machine
right like like there's a millions of
machines out there
that are less famous than those two but
those are individuals that
literally hit the jackpot of loving what
they do so much and then naturally being
great at it
and i feel like that about my
entrepreneurial life i feel like
it was my destiny i was doing it at six
not because my parents told me
or because i read a book or someone
inspired me
i just was literally drawn to the light
i feel like a firefly
in one of those zap machines like i just
had no choice
and um and i have fought
against a lot of things to be in that
place including what i was supposed to
be doing in school
judgment of parents and teachers and
when you're when you're 8 and 9
12 and 14 years old that judgment is
heavy
you don't like being called a loser by
teachers and your parents friends
and i was a lot by the way and um
that builds chips on your shoulders and
that builds
conviction so i had the strength
emotionally to fight for my
entrepreneurship
then and obviously
you know and obviously now it's popular
and by the way
there's undercurrents of it being
demonized right and so you know
these things have been flow as long as
you stay true to
your kindness and your process i think
it will always work out
that net i'd love for you one day to do
a book just on your philosophies of life
because so many people run at you with
entrepreneurship but if they realize
that how you run a business is how
people should look at their lives for
happiness is the goal dude it's
beautiful to see and we need more of you
but just a quick segue into
you had a beautiful video called how to
build a tallest building recently
and it's fantastic because there are two
ways to build a tallest building either
one build the tallest building or two
tear everyone's down
and going into kindness i know
no man is an island so you've created a
phenomenal team around you and it's
continually growing like i remember
the professionalism dealing with your
team years ago and i was just astounded
how much
they love what they do and would you
just
uh as a like a fellow entrepreneur
speaking to someone else what
do you do that attracts incredible
talent to you that aligns with your
mission
i realize that i don't think it's
incredible talent
when it comes to me and it's my job to
make them incredible
which then makes it very attractive now
talent it has nothing to do with me so
to your point
i believe that most people have things
in them
but i think most people die without
finding them
and so what i think i'm extremely good
at is being a reverse engineer and an
architect
and a conductor and so what i do is
i listen to them and i watch them and i
try to put them in positions to succeed
and i remind and i and i and i feel a
responsibility towards them i don't
think
i don't think team garyvee is at the
service of garyvee the character
i believe that i'm in the service of
them which then
is probably why you felt what you felt
about them because they really then like
me because
they taste what i'm doing for them which
only enhances the whole process
and then they can find being their best
selves whether i've guided them
or whether the process has allowed them
to find it you used a really important
word their service
uh evan who this channel is he took me
aside one day and said
if you change your life from trying to
serve yourself and trying to make
yourself successful and big and start
just
adding value to others and serving them
watch what happens to your life
dude in two weeks two weeks i had like
everything i've ever wanted and it was
like it was like a
magic like kind of cheat code on a
computer game so
i'm glad to hear someone of your stature
using the word service because that's
what it is it's serving
others adding value to their lives it's
hard to do that
it's hard to do that if you're not happy
so
what the reason so many people tear
other people's buildings down is because
they're unhappy
are they unhappy because they don't like
what they do or they're unhappy because
they're jealous and envious of others
they're unhappy because they don't like
themselves
and that's in just their core that
everything they do
i believe it's often implemented in
the parenting they were receiving
and and obviously i mean look freud and
many other like this has been figured
out long before us
nature nurtures real and so i think it's
a mix
i think it's a mix of dna and i think
it's a mix of parenting and i think it's
a mix of the neighborhood slash
environment you grow up in so
like for me i have the kindest mother i
grew up
dog [ __ ] poor to them like middle class
but
lived poor cause my parents spent no
money on anything
completely accountable oldest kid you
know
merchant at 14 old school 1930 style
come to the family like
schlep two bucks an hour um
fully accountable never given and
and so you know
self-esteem and and work ethic right and
here i am
a very obvious byproduct of the
circumstances
so i'm grateful for the people
in my life that i'm very close to that
weren't as luxurious
to those circumstances even though it
didn't seem luxurious at the time
i've watched some of them whether with
my guidance or without it
go from a two to an eight no different
than i now have
better muscles than i used to it can be
done
if you work the exercise of your brain
you just have to execute
positivity and practicality in your mind
over and over and over again
you need to surround yourself with it
you need to suffocate excuses
and you need to uh lean into that so
yeah i think most people are jealous
because they're so unhappy someone
else's happiness hurts their feelings
i'm going to take it in it it's funny
like talking to you like this but
you're like hitting deep within i'm
going man there's people who've said
to me i'm like i feel for them i feel
like i want to i do too
the reason the reason i'm here still
at the top of my game is because i know
how to deal with hate
and that hate needs to be dealt with
compassion and sympathy
not countered with hate yeah
so for all these years you've been doing
this
uh has during like a dark moment or a
moment where you just like
you've hit a wall what's pushed you
through that like because we've all had
that dark night of the soul
simplicity uh how so
are the 8 to 12 people that i love by
far the most
alive and healthy yes get over your
guru man i hate that word it's really
it's really true and i you know and even
like and i also don't like i don't want
to be
guru and but i know that i talk like
some weird dude that lives
like i like sometimes when i talk i even
it's funny how you reacted i almost
reacted to it the same way because i can
hear myself speak i'm like
oh i'm one of those weird that lives in
the alps
that you go and visit and drink some
weird potion of like a mix of tea and
like rattlesnake guts
and i say something and then you leave
and it's like like i
i keep it very simple i'm simpleish
dude i think it's your new wine you got
this magic new wine and by the way
congratulations on empathy that's such
great news so
and even to you celebrating these
victories now like you have
shows exactly where your heart is
yeah it's it's you know to your point
like
you know yesterday i have one of the
more significant business wins in my
career
in selling empathy to consolation for
hefty hefty hefty eight figures
and honestly bro yesterday i replaced my
icloud it got corrupt
i've literally had the iphone since they
came out so 13 years i think
i've had the same icloud so i have a new
one and
like my eye messages were crashing every
sec it was just a disaster for almost a
half a year i was using whatsapp i was
trying to pick you know
nonetheless i'm literally more excited
that my phone is cruising today
than that i sold a major i had one of
the major weight
it's simplicity that's it
and i mean and i mean for everybody
who's looking listening or watching
right now with cynicism because they
don't know me
or they don't necessarily like me
you're eventually going to realize how
true it is i love my process
the trophies are fine but they're just
as fine as the booze
the booing from the crowd or the
super bowl trophy they're just the same
i am
i'm just in it in my little world and
i'm trying to make a nice impact
and i want to create a blueprint that's
replicable to others
and i want to bounce with some really
solid legacy
you know i speak to a lot of people man
a lot
and you're just you're as real as the
person
in person as the youtube video as the
tick tock account
and it's refreshing and i think more
people need this
real kind of like punch in the head to
be like hello wake up
you're great you can do good things so
you really can
people people think they're negative and
bad and what they are they're hurt
they're hurt they're wounded they're
scared
and um gary i'm negative no you're not
you look at every situation
trying to figure out what's going to go
wrong because you're wounded and you're
trying to protect yourself because
you're emotionally soft
and once you realize that all of a
sudden you don't judge yourself as bad
and that just changes the whole context
going away from i'm bad to i'm hurting
but i can fix it is like the biggest
shift ever
that's the sound bite there it is there
it is
there it is you can have it for
tick-tock but look guys definitely gonna
take it
it's gonna be up i'm gonna let you run
because i know you're busy
but thank you so much for being on the
bow show your thank you star
your your vibes were very sweet i
appreciate it thank you
have a great day man bye-bye if you want
to see the bow show interview with wim
hof check out the video right there next
to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there it is all science
data rich data cold data
your happiness your strength your health
is up to you
what is your choice